♪～
～♪
（シャンクス）こう伝えろ
本当に今から俺と戦うか
ロードポーネグリフを置いて消えるか
選べと
（ナレーション）一方 エッグヘッドは
裏切り者の暗躍により大混乱
その裏切り者とは…
（ベガパンク）ヨーク！
（ヨーク）ウフフッ
出ておいで
ねえ みんな　お願い
あたいを助けて
ウフフッ
それじゃあ早速 聞いてほしいんだけど…
あーん… んんっ
なんと困ったことに世界政府は…
（飲み込む音）
（ヨーク）ステラだけじゃなく
あたいのことも消すことにしたみたい
信じられない　あったまきた　許せない
そうだよね？　何か言って
（Ｓ-スネーク）はい 許せません
（ヨーク）遅いっ
それなら こっちにも作戦があるわ
（ヨーク）で…
（骨が落ちる音）
（ヨーク）あなたたちには
ひとまず邪魔者を片づけてほしいの
フロンティアドームは閉じたから
あたいとステラ　そして地下の人質を残して
全員 殺しちゃって
（一同）了解
…で あなたたちが暴れると―
それを命じた者は誰かって犯人探しが始まる
もしバレたら あたい 強さじゃ
あのメンバーには かなわないから…
（ヨーク）Ｓ-スネーク
（Ｓ-スネーク）はい
彼らの目の前で あたいを…
（ヨーク）やっつけたフリをして
（Ｓ-スネーク）はい
人目のない時に技は解いてね
（ヨーク）フフッ
それとラボ内には
壊しちゃいけない場所があるから教えるね
みんなも よーく聞いて
じゃ ハンティング…
スタート
（研究員たちの悲鳴）
（地響き）
（研究員）急げ　全員 船に乗れ
（研究員）エッグヘッドから脱出するぞ
（研究員たちの荒い息）
（ユースタス・キッド）
準備はいいか？　お前ら
（パパス）ヒヒッ
（ポンプ）ハハハッ
（キッド）相手は赤髪
（ワイヤー）四皇(よんこう)の次が また四皇とはな
（ヒート）武者震いが止まらねえぜ
（キッド）ハッハハッ　いい調子じゃねえか
野郎ども
動きだした時代は止まらねえ
俺たち―
キッド海賊団のようにな
誰一人 遅れるな
死ぬ気で ついてこい
（ダイブ）エヘヘヘッ
ん～…
（一同）おおーっ！
（ゲロティニー）よう よう キッド海賊団
（キッド）ああ？
（ゲロティニー）
我らが大頭 赤髪のシャンクスに…
（キラー）来たか 傘下ども
（ゲロティニー）かえると… あっ 会めっ…
（クルー）船長　噛んだっ
会えると思うなゲロ
（キッド）んん…
（フガー）ほのとーりゃ フガフガ…
（クルー）おやっさん　入れ歯
（フガー）フガ…
（キッド）うっ… ん？
（プルル）そうよ バカ
嫌いっ
大頭ちゃんには
ぜーったい会わせないんだから
（クルー）すごい勇気よ 姫
ううっ… おい
（キッド）おいって
（キラー）んっ
（キッドの舌打ち）
（キッド）正気か？
（海賊たちのわめき声）
（キッド）あれが赤髪の傘下？
ここは新世界だよなあ？
んんっ…
（キラー）言いたいことは分かるが
有名な顔も交ざってる
油断は するな
どんな雑魚だろうと手は抜かねえが…
（クルー）そっちじゃねえ　こっちだ
（クルー）違う　こっちだ
（クルー）おっと　ヘヘッ
（クルー）んん… あっ
（シャンクス）そろそろ出航だ
（クルー）お頭
あいつら 止めに出ちまった
（シャンクス）すぐ引かせろ
被害が出てからじゃ遅い
（海賊たち）おい おい おい
（シャンクス）ん？
（海賊たち）待て 待て 待て
（足をくじく音）
（海賊）うわっ　ああっ
（海賊）ぎっ…
（海賊）ぐっ…
（海賊たち）何 言ってんだ 大頭
（シャンクス）いや 何やってんだ お前ら
（海賊）あんたにゃ指一本 触れさせねえよ
（２人）おうっ
ん… ああ 気持ちだけは うれしいよ
だが海には出るなよ
（海賊）てめえ　さっさと どけろ
（走る足音）
（海賊たち）ん？
ヒッ
（リナリア）行かないで
（海賊）俺たちにも やらせろ
おっ おおっ…
（海賊たちの笑い声）
（シャンクス）ううっ
おい おい お前ら…
（海賊）フフッ　つれねえなあ 大頭
（シャンクス）ああ…
（リナリア）そうよ　置いていかないで
コラコラ
（ドリー）こうなりゃ四皇も形なしだな
（ブロギー）ガバババババッ　違(ちげ)えねえ
（海賊）嫌よ　大頭 もう行っちゃうの？
（海賊）そうだぜ 大頭
やっと会えたってのによ
（シャンクス）悪いな
ここには少し立ち寄っただけだ
（シャンクス）あっ ほら お前ら　離れろ
（リナリア）ん～
（リナリア）ああっ
（シャンクス）
長居したせいで大物に出くわしちまった
さあ 道を空けてくれ
（海賊）いつでも呼んでくれ
（シャンクス）ああ
（海賊）愛してるぜ～
（シャンクス）ハハッ
（シャンクス）
ああ 何度も言うが船も引けよ
うちの傘下は“弱い”で有名なんだからよ
（海賊）ブッ ブハッ
ダーッハハハハッ
言ってくれるよ 本当に もう
（オリ婆(ばあ)）おかげさまで生き残ってら
あーたの旗に守られてさ
（シャンクス）ああ
敵より寿命に気いつけな オリ婆
（オリ婆）ホアッハッハッ
やかましいよ 大頭 この野郎
（ライムジュース）大人気だな お頭
（シャンクス）やれやれだ
（ルウ）お頭　いいよ
俺たちで やっとくっと…
（シャンクス）おいおい 30億の首だぞ
若者の成長速度を見くびるな
（ヤソップ）ん～
（シャンクス）しかし あいつら
ワノ国の傷は もう癒えたのか？
（ヤソップ）ヒヒッ
（シャンクス）しかし あいつら
ワノ国の傷は もう癒えたのか？
（ヤソップ）ああ 元気そうだぜ
戦う気 満々だ
なら いいが…
黒ひげの情報は入ったか？
いや 海賊島は確実に出てるが…
ワノ国に現れると思ったがな
ホンゴウ
（ホンゴウ）
ほい “キャプテン”キッドのデータ
（クルー）さすがホンゴウさん　準備がいい
（ホンゴウ）うるせえ　さっさと運べ
（シャンクス）出身はサウスブルーか
だいぶ暴れ回ってきたな
（キッド）何隻いる？
（キラー）９隻
手配書で見た顔も ちらほら
ゲロ？
（キッド）うううう…
うおおおおっ
相手なんざ誰であれ関係ねえ
10秒で全滅させてやる
この―
電磁砲(ダムド･パンク)で
（海賊）おおっ おわああっ
（海賊）船が引っ張られてねえか？
（海賊）あっ 何だありゃ
大砲？
（海賊たちのどよめき）
（キッド）ギャアギャアと
よく ほえやがるなあ
雑魚に用はねえ
俺たちの邪魔をするやつはなあ！
（シャンクス）んっ
消し飛べ
（ゲロティニー）ひゃああっ
（海賊たちの叫び声）
（フガー）ふがあああっ
（海賊）ああっ
（キッド）出てこい 赤髪ーっ
マズい
船団を左右へ
どうした お頭
（シャンクス）ドリー　ブロギー　構えろ
（ドリーとブロギー）よし きたっ
（シャンクス）取り舵(かじ)
被害が でかすぎる
（ベン・ベックマン）
やべえ未来が見えたようだ
消し飛べえっ！
（シャンクス）さすがだな
うおおおおっ
うっ…
赤髪っ
（シャンクス）神避(かむさり)
（バブルガム）うわあああっ
（キッド）くっ…
（キッド）うっ ううっ うう…
（キッドのうめき声と足音）
（キラー）相棒
（キッド）ん…
（キッド）おう
（キラー）もう目の前だ
（キッド）ああ
ハッ フッフッフッフッ
俺たちゃ勝った
ロードポーネグリフも あと１つ
海賊王まで あと１つ
カイドウ　ビッグ・マム　赤髪　ハッ
旧時代の雑魚どもめ　俺たちが最強
俺たちについてこれるやつは いねえ
海賊王になるのは
俺だあっ
（キラー）ファーッファッファッ
（キッド）あ？　キラー てめえ
何 笑って…
（クルー）お頭 お頭っ
（クルー）目を開けてくれ
（クルー）キッド！
（クルー）キッドさーんっ
（ヒップ）あっ…　お頭っ
（モッシュ）お頭が動かねえ
（モッシュ）死んじまう
（パパス）クソッ
援護に入ったキラーさんまで…
（キラーが血を吐く音）
（モッシュの舌打ち）
ううっ
（ヒート）降参だ　赤髪　助けてくれ
お頭を殺さないでくれっ
（ヒート）くっ…
（エマのすすり泣き）
おい エマ　あれ持ってこい
（エマ）えっ？
（ヒート）早くっ
（エマ）ああっ
（ヒート）こ… これが
ロードポーネグリフ 全部だ
命だけは勘弁してくれ
うっ うううっ
ああっ
（３人）あっ ああああ…
（ロックスター）大頭　こっちへ
（３人）あっ
（ダイブ）あっ ああああ…
（ＵＫ(ユーケー)）おっ おい　島のほう
（ヒート）うっ… ああっ
やばいのが―
来る
ぬううううっ
（ブロギー）むううううっ
ゲギャギャギャギャギャギャ
おいチビ人間　人の故郷に銃口 向けたら…
ガババババババッ
同じ目に遭う覚悟をしろよ
（２人）覇国(はこく)っ
あっ…
（ナレーション）新世界 エルバフにて
懸賞金30億の海賊―
ユースタス・“キャプテン”キッド率いる
キッド海賊団―
壊滅
♪～
～♪
（リリス）よう
わしは しがない天才科学者―
ドクターベガパンクの１人 リリスじゃ
（エジソン）
同じくベガパンクのエジソンやぜ
今回は こいつ　シャンクス
赤髪海賊団の
大頭にして
四皇の一角
ルフィが
海賊になる―
きっかけとなった
男じゃ
（エジソン）３月９日生まれで
好物はキムチチャーハンとロブスターやぜ
幼い頃は
ロジャー海賊団に
海賊見習いとして
乗船していたんじゃ
同じく四皇の１人であるバギーとは
この時からの腐れ縁じゃのう
（エジソン）やがて赤髪海賊団を
結成したシャンクスは
しばらくの間 イーストブルー
フーシャ村を拠点としとったんや
そこで出会ったのがルフィ
ルフィは シャンクスの自由な生きざまに
憧れを抱き 海賊になると決意したんやな
シャンクスはルフィを守るため
左腕を失ったんじゃ
そして自分の麦わら帽子を預けた
（シャンクス）いつか きっと返しに来い
立派な海賊になってな
（エジソン）今やルフィも
四皇の一角を担う大海賊や
２人の再会の時は近いのか
こればっかりは
パンクレコーズでも予測不可能やぜ
今日のコーナーは ここまで
見たからには研究費のカンパ よろしくな
（エジソン）また次回やぜ
（ナレーション）海賊島 ハチノスにて
奴隷たちを解放するため―
おとりとなって脱出を図るコビー
その行く手を阻むべく
島中の海賊が襲いかかる
孤立無援の中 コビーは正義を貫き
解放への道を切り開けるのか
（モンキー・Ｄ・ルフィ）
次回「ワンピース」
“走れコビー！
決死の脱出作戦！”
海賊王に 俺はなる！